Sudan's military leaders held talks with
the Emir of Qatar Sheikh tamim bin Hamad
al-tani Abdul fatal Burhans one day
visit is to discuss bilateral relations
and aid for Sudan but Han has already
visited neighboring South Sudan and
Egypt and is expected to travel to Saudi
Arabia in the coming days
earlier the Army Chief issued a decree
dissolving the rapid support forces the
Army in the paramilitary group led by
Mohammed hamdan Douglas have been locked
in a battle for control for nearly five
months burhan says the move is a
consequence of the group's Rebellion
against the state
Walid madibo is found in president as
Sudan policy Forum he joins me here on
set here in Doha thank you for your time
sir what is general burhan hoping to
achieve by this visit here to Qatar
uh the General's strategy is not clear
uh if he is seeking reconciliation uh
then he is probably thinking about uh
repatriation or rebuilding of the
country in the aftermath of the war
but if he is seeking confrontation with
the paramilitary group then probably he
wants arms he wants aid for the
population in Sudan especially in the
northern part of the country and the
western part of the country so for me
his strategy is not clear because by
dissolving the rsf then he has already
closed the doors for any sort of
reconciliation unless he is using that
as as a card by which he aims to push
the rsf against the wall and forces it
to give in more to the demands of the
state of Sudan what about qatar's role
here when it comes to mediation they've
been successful when it comes to other
conflicts
Qatar is is now presiding over the
committee for Less developed countries
so from an economic and financial
perspective it's a very important
country uh also historically and
traditionally speaking it has helped
strike uh the the peace agreement it's a
guaranteer now for the Juba agreement so
it's it's very well perceived among the
Saudis Sudanese politicians and the
Sudanese public
however they there seems to be a shift
now after the war because prior to the
War uh Qatar X I mean extended the
invitation to the Prime Minister hamduk
but he didn't make it to Qatar until he
was the regime was toppled uh so now
given the fact that the UAE is perceived
as an ally for the rsf then
Qatar more more
agreeably it's going to be on the side
of General brand that's what Buran
thinks but I'm not sure how the Dynamics
is going to outplay yeah as you say I
mean the gulf countries they are
definitely not all on the same side when
it comes to the different parties in
Sudan I mean how how difficult does that
make any sort of resolution to the
conflict it's going to be a very
difficult but now is a Qatar is not
trying to replace the the American Saudi
deal but if it could possibly help with
supporting that deal and helping it go
through
it's going to play a very important role
in the in the very uh in the in the very
future in the very coming future and I I
think even though it's very difficult
for the Sudanese leaders now to swallow
the importance of having to deal with
the UAE they will ultimately have to
deal with the UAE because it is a main
supporter for the rsf
really interesting to talk to you Waleed
madibo founder and president of the
Sudan policy Forum here in the studio in
Doha thank you